foreign
[Music]
so um if you're here at next uh on this
startup AIML track you've probably
noticed things are a little bit
different in the AIML world than the
last 12 months just a few things have
changed
um and so we're really at a pretty big
inflection point for AI here right
um what's happened here is that we're
now interacting with these massive
Foundation models using a completely
different Paradigm than we've
traditionally interacted with AI and ml
so these are multimodal models that we
can interact with through the Simplicity
of natural language we can build
incredibly powerful consumer experiences
so many of you probably started out your
awareness of these Foundation models by
using consumer chat Bots or stable
diffusion or some of those other
products and very quickly those consumer
Solutions have jumped into the
Enterprise and business space so we're
seeing really rapid adoption by
companies up and down the scale from
Enterprises to seed stage startups
wanting to transform their business
wanting to build products and wanting to
provide generative AI experiences to
their users
so this is a pretty big change from
where we were at from an AIML
perspective in years past so if you've
been in the AIML space for a while you
probably know that the early days of
AIML required a lot of really uh expert
resources to build uh tune train and
maintain models so you had models that
were built from scratch
they had to be trained on enormous data
sets and training and maintaining those
models was no small job you had very
large teams that were responsible for
this which essentially meant that most
small companies were kind of locked out
of using these tools you had to have
large expert expensive resources and
teams in order to implement these
Solutions
and furthermore you didn't know exactly
what you were going to get so you might
spend a long time building a model you
might spend a long time training a model
and then all of a sudden you're testing
that model and you're getting results
that are maybe not quite aligned with
your expectations
so models were powerful but a bit
difficult to control and certainly very
resource intensive to manage and deploy
but the AI and mL of today is for
everyone so today we can offer you
pre-trained Foundation models and task
specific models that can be tuned and
deployed with no code so any developer
can can find these models and deploy
them we have model options for every
task so regardless if you're doing
translation or you want natural language
generation or image generation we have a
wide variety wide variety of model
choices for you
in addition we have robust tooling and
infrastructure support to make that
maintenance incredibly easy for you so
what this all means is that any
developer any company whatever stage
you're at can get started today with
very minimal expertise or background in
Ai and ml
and so the solution that Google cloud is
offering specifically in this space to
empower developers to get started with
AIML quickly is vertex model Garden
so just to provide a little bit of
context if you're newer to Google cloud
or newer to Google Cloud AI vertex is a
platform has actually been in market for
a number of years and initially vertex
was built to provide an easy tooling
solution for developers looking to build
and maintain their own models and so
essentially we had an infrastructure set
up so that you could bring your own
models you could tune them you could
train them and you could maintain them
and deploy them to an endpoint
model Garden extends all that capability
by offering open source and first party
models directly in an easy to find
interface which can then be deployed on
vertex so you can continue to bring your
own model but you can also find a number
of models in model Garden
and so really what this experience is is
a One-Stop Discovery shop so we're going
to see in the demo in just a minute
um it's easy to search easy to find and
easy to filter for the capabilities that
you want based on the modality of the
model the topics that you're interested
in or the capabilities of the model
itself
you can use Foundation models directly
as a frozen pre-trained base model or
you can tune those Foundation models
using a one-click stop from vertex
and for the first party models you
actually have direct API access to task
specific Solutions like Vision speech
doc Ai and other modalities
so what we're seeing in the foundation
and task specific models right now that
customers are using is that even though
there is a trend towards multi-modality
customers are still interested in Choice
across modalities so that means that
there's very few customers that are
picking one model for all of their
language needs or one model for all of
their image needs instead selection
variety and choice are key criteria for
developers looking to deploy these
Foundation models and so you can see
here these are some of the foundation
models that we offer today across
modalities and this list is is growing
every day
so hopefully that gave you a little bit
of basis
around what you can expect in model
garden and vertex but you might be
wondering how you can actually get
started with these things we're going to
actually go through a demo in just a
moment but I want to give you some tips
before we even think about how to get
into that environment
so before you start on your journey of
deploying a model you're going to want
to Define your use case clearly and the
reason that this is important is because
as you select your model you're going to
want to have those criteria in mind so
what are you building who are you
building for and why are you building it
this will help your model selection
process go a lot easier
number two
start testing with a pre-trained model
often customers think that they need to
tune a model right away because they
have a very specific application or use
case in mind well we definitely
encourage tuning and we offer a number
of different ways to tune we always
recommend that you start with the base
model for one it's easy you can start
doing it right away and number two it
gives you a sense of where the
functionality or or output gaps might be
so once you get those results from the
base model for example you might get a
sense of what types of test data that
you want to use for your adapter tuning
or for whatever tuning that you want to
implement so starting with that Frozen
base model always a great step
three obviously you're going to want to
assess the results and the data that you
need for additional training so the good
news about using that base model to
start with is you're going to get a
bunch of data from it you're going to
get a sense of the performance of that
model ideally you're testing multiple
models if you want to kind of get a
better sense of the ecosystem that's
available to you and you're going to
want to compare and decide do you need
additional tuning is this the right
model for your use case do you need to
do some additional exploring
and then finally once you're kind of
narrowing in on the model and the
training that you want to do you're
going to want to train and test using
vertex model evaluation and other tools
available in the Google Cloud ecosystem
so again thinking back to that previous
slide about the old days of AIML you
know testing and benchmarking was really
really difficult because it was often
done ad hoc by developers writing code
for the specific testing and tuning
needs with vertex these days we have a
nice toolkit that requires or that
allows you to get started really really
quickly without writing any code at all
all right
and with that I'm actually just going to
hop into a demo here
and give me one second I just want to
make sure this is uh
clicking through here all right
beautiful okay
success on the first click okay so what
you're seeing right now is model Garden
so if you have a Google Cloud account
you can find this today this is GA so um
you can see there on the left we have a
menu that allows you to filter by
modality by task by a few different uh
criteria so I would definitely recommend
that if you're just getting into model
Garden for the first time you might
start exploring there based off of your
use case and just sort of poke around
but let's kind of Imagine a use case
here so let's say I'm a developer at a
biotech or a healthcare startup and I
want a model that's specifically been
fine-tuned on medical data
so I'm going to go in search for medical
I found a pretty promising result here
Palmyra Med and right now what you're
seeing here is the model card and so the
model card every model in model Garden
has a model card and it's going to give
you a bunch of core information about
the model's performance about its
attributes about other kind of important
information that you need to know so I
can see here that this model excels at
summarizing medical information which is
terrific I want to summarize medical
reports so this model is looking pretty
promising to me already and the great
thing about model Garden as you're
seeing here on the screen is that most
models come embedded with a collab
notebook so that you can actually test
the model directly from that model card
and so what you're seeing right now is
collab so you probably might be familiar
with this environment this is our
notebook environment
um and so all of this is set up you'll
notice that this all came pre-packaged
all the metadata was there I'm just
running this directly from that model
card page and so basically what I'm
doing here is I'm providing a little bit
of metadata about my project about my
account about the buckets that I want to
send the data to
um otherwise everything's written here
I'm not writing any code and so I'm just
going to run a few slides or a few cells
after I provide this metadata here
and again this is something that you
guys can do today in model Garden right
away
and so once I provide that metadata I'm
going to initialize the vertex API
I'm going to define the docker container
a few other common functions
and
this is all being done just through
Quicks again I didn't write any of this
code and then finally I'm going to
upload and deploy my model and so what
you're seeing right here apologies for
the small font is some configurations
around the Hardwares and hardware and
accelerators so again you can choose
that you know choose whatever is right
for you based off of your location based
off of your cost structure and then
ultimately I'm gonna
deploy that model so
um you saw that instantaneously that was
the magic of time lapse that actually
takes about 20 minutes so if it takes
you 20 minutes don't be surprised but we
now have a deployed model
and so what you're seeing right here is
actually there's a few pre-written
prompts
um and so you can go in there and either
edit those prompts run them directly
write your own prompts uh adjust the
parameters so for this particular model
we have two parameters one of them is
Max new token the other is temperature
those are just settings to determine the
length of the output as well as the
statistical variance so temperature Hot
Topic in LMS right now but you can
adjust that as you need to
and so I've decided to deploy my model
I'm back now in model registry you can
see that I've found Palmyra Med right
there
and so let's say I'm ready to put this
into production I'm going to go and
click deploy and deploy and test and
then I'm going to deploy to an endpoint
and so again I want to I want to mention
that I'm creating an API from that model
again having not written any code this
is all purely from The Notebook and from
the UI and so once I'm in this deploy to
endpoint tab there's just a few simple
steps I have to step through here so
number one I'm going to name my endpoint
I'm also going to select the location of
the hardware where I want to deploy it
and adjust a few access settings if you
would prefer different ones you can
either manage your own keys or have
Google manage your keys for you through
the standard settings
and so once I've sort of decided on
those settings and that I'm happy with
my results I can continue on
and so this page is just going to let me
figure out how to distribute my compute
resources so this is really important in
terms of scaling my model appropriately
again these are things that you can
modify after you've deployed your model
as well but to get started you'll just
want to make a few decisions about how
you're going to distribute traffic which
machines you want the number of compute
nodes all that kind of stuff and again
the good thing about vertex is that you
get a pretty robust set of documentation
to kind of help you make those decisions
if you're feeling overwhelmed with the
number of boxes to click or the number
of fields to fill in the good news is
there's quite a bit of helpful tips here
so once I've done all that I'm just
gonna
modify my traffic split here continue to
go on
and then finally I'm going to implement
model monitoring so model monitoring is
optional you don't have to implement it
but obviously we strongly recommend that
you use model monitoring model
monitoring will make sure that your
responses are not drifting away from
your desired output so again this isn't
something you have to build yourself
it's something that Google Cloud offers
as a solution you just need to opt into
it
all right and then finally uh getting
towards the last few pages here there's
a couple more pages that I can select on
so um in terms of the monitoring
objective there's a few different
criteria that you can use either
training serving SKU detection or
prediction drift detection
um since I didn't tune this model myself
I'm going to use prediction drift
detection but you can always use
training serving SKU detection it's
quite a mouthful of words if you do fine
tune your model
um and then finally just a few more
Selections in terms of the criteria that
I want to make for monitoring and other
alert thresholds that I can optionally
use at this stage
and I'm ready to deploy
all right
beautiful so there's my end point right
there in the model registry
and that step also typically takes about
20 to 30 minutes again through the magic
of time WAP so I'm just going to hop
over and show you what the API actually
looks like once I've set it up Google
cloud makes it super easy for you to get
started as a developer here we're giving
you an SDK as well as some uh some
python samples if you want to start
running that in your Cloud console or
your CLI of choice
all right I do want to mention one other
thing though if you do want to tune your
model there is a training uh a training
tab in Google Cloud that allows you to
do this so
right here you're seeing a couple uh
examples of data sets or annotation sets
that you could use to do that training
as well as the objectives that you can
set so again we've chosen a medical
model here so these are probably not the
right training data sets or annotation
sets but it gives you a sort of sense of
the the options you have
one option that you can consider if
you're looking for open source data sets
is using a solution like Kegel so for
example
this is the view in Kegel right now of
just Healthcare data sets ranked by
usability and you can see they have
quite a bit all of these are open
sourced and scored
so I go into the disease symptom
prediction tab I can explore this data a
little bit they have sort of the model
card equivalent on their data sets as
well as upvoting and a few other
criteria and I can see here on the right
that it has a usability score of 9.7 out
of 10 which is amazing
so just to tie back to model Garden here
what I want to emphasize is that that
experience can be had on any of the
models that you can find in model
Gardens so that isn't just unique to
this particular model or this particular
functionality that ease of deployment is
available on any model that you're going
to find in model Garden
all right
make sure this
is beautiful okay and with that I'm
going to invite May to come up and tell
you a little bit about how Ryder is
innovating in the space of generative AI
thank you
hi everyone I am so excited to tell you
um about writer and how we're working
with Google and vertex and there's a
small announcement at the end that we're
very excited about but first I want to
understand the audience a little bit
um
who works at a startup smaller than 200
people
okay smaller than 100 people
okay who is generative AI native I hate
that term
okay who's building a generative AI
application or feature into their
product
okay cool what are you guys doing
I'm joking but um what really what is
the interest level what brings you to
the session today
funny that no one on this side raised
their hand
okay awesome awesome wonderful
um well so excited and hopefully um we
will answer and it fulfilled both sides
of the room
um we've got five models in vertex
Garden as of
um uh vertex AI model Garden as of a
couple of weeks ago including uh Palmyra
Med
um which we uh have uh have open sourced
actually
so all five models are free and open
source and a lot of times when we talk
to a customer who had been using one of
our open source models
um that was on a platform not vertex our
best models are on vertex
um folks are like so
this actually works really well what is
the commercial offering and why would I
pay you and I've had literally like cios
of telcos ask us this question and you
know for both sides of the room I think
um
once you really dig deep into just how
hard it is to go from a POC or something
that works some of the time most of the
time to real production scale and it has
to work all the time and be really good
um that is where so much of the effort
lies in so much of the complexity and so
the the commercial part of writer is
really everything we've built on top of
the models and we're going to talk about
the models and how we built them as well
too for you know the folks interested in
in scope and what it takes but what we
have put together as our Enterprise
offering what the you know logos on the
previous slide we're we're doing is what
we think are really the the three
essential parts of building a generative
AI application that's ready for uh
production
um yes you've got the model
but paired with that for us is oops
um AI guard rails that include a ton of
post-processing and some of those
post-processing services do use
um uh llms as well but a lot of them are
our NLP
um and we augment most of our use cases
with a Knowledge Graph not a vector
database which we we should talk about
as well um where our learnings came from
for for that and the result is a product
that allows folks to very quickly spin
up multiple generative AI use cases
so uh we have been doing this now going
on
um two and a half years so um my
co-founder and I were in the translation
machine translation and localization
business before so we've been working
with Bert and um uh Transformers for for
years and really seeing the the
generative capabilities is why we
started writer in early 2020 so the the
good news for us is
um in this incredibly
um hot AI market we've been able to talk
to people about use cases that have been
in production for for a long time and
we're going to walk through some of
those but the the story here really is
in um you know what starts at the very
Foundation which is the the the llm
um and for us the way that our
architecture works is uh the the model
and the knowledge graph can actually be
hosted inside of somebody's private
Cloud
um this is part of our announcement a
little bit later we are excited to
partner with with Google on making that
happen within gcp and then the the
platform above is really customizable
um
most of what generative AI is good at we
can characterize and kind of classify
across three types of applications
create analyze govern
and so the the use cases and whether you
are
prompt engineering plus fine tuning or
some prompt engineering but then you're
really building that index
whether you are doing a bit of prompt
engineering but then like you know it's
multiple layers of fine tuning so much
of it comes down to what the use case is
and what kind of capabilities are you
drawing on
um
for us
everything that we are able to do today
and the Enterprise use cases that I'll
walk through in a bit
really are a result of some of the
foundational no pun intended decisions
that we've made for for the company uh
those folks ask us all the time uh look
layers you know one through five really
look like they could sit on any model
why did you build your own and yeah a
big part of that is being able to
control how all those layers work
together and be able to over time really
invest in the increasing capabilities
that can still be hosted by a customer
in their own cloud
can still be
fine-tuned in ways that aren't you know
overly complex or require too much data
ways that they can be inspectable as
well so so we've got customers who do
ask to
audit what is in our training data we've
got really strict
um
from a data perspective
policies as it relates to what goes into
the foundation models training what goes
into Knowledge Graph what goes into the
use case fine-tuning and prompt
engineering and where those live and how
they get shared between customers tldr
they don't get shared between customers
at all at any of those levels but people
really are interested in these decisions
now and for those of you who are
building generative AI into your
applications the the depth and
sophistication of the security
questionnaires we get now the level of
inspection rights people want to have on
knowing what is in those models even
requests to indemnify we have now
actually indemnified customers in both
financial services and Healthcare you
know as a result of just being so
confident around IP and copyright risks
so none of that would have been possible
if we didn't develop our own models our
whole business wouldn't have been
wouldn't have been possible
so
from a deployment options perspective
that is obviously another big reason to
own your own stock and and not
be too dependent on uh other models if
the applications really are needing to
live in somebody's environment as a
result of
security or privacy Etc that's become
really important and that played a big
role in our pursuing uh the the
relationship with Google and we've
always been a gcp shop from uh I mean
literally like the first dollar of
credits I think we might even still get
credits I don't know if that's allowed
but uh you know for us uh you know
partnering with gcp and vertex was a was
it was a no-brainer and Google in
general so you know that had a big role
in um
kind of the the way that we have gone to
Market
the the knowledge graph uh this is uh
proprietary this can live in somebody's
private Cloud so we've got folks who
host this within their GPC environments
uh and it what we're what we're doing
essentially is
um using the model
to create the metadata for everything
that's in the knowledge graph And Then
There are a set of compression
algorithms that decide what we're going
to compress and what we're not going to
compress what we're going to feed into
the the the model raw and the result is
a much higher level of accuracy and much
lower cost over time actually for the
kinds of use cases where you really have
a high refresh rate for the knowledge
that needs to be in that environment and
you know the the reason we think full
stock generative AI makes a lot of sense
is most folks don't want to be
rebuilding uh this infrastructure for
you know each of the one of dozens of
digital assistants that folks will want
to build you know on any given on any
given team so this has been a really big
part of how we've expanded the footprint
of the product from our original create
use cases to our analyze and and govern
use cases
and lastly you know this is the third
leg of of the product around AI guard
rails and and brand governance and you
know folks end up realizing as they're
trying to take uh applications to
production that
um you know an end user has really high
expectations for uh what comes out of
our AI apps and you want to say but like
look you're 60 faster than you were
before and like suddenly folks want to
be 100 faster or 200 faster right they
want the solution
um uh uh completed fully and we have
seen so much of um
sort of that last mile really be about
um the the post-processing that needs to
happen to make sure that um uh that the
answer or the generation is exactly what
the the you know impresses the user or
that the user would do manually
so um I thought we could spend time
going through use cases most of these
folks are folks that we we share with
with gcp
um and not everybody is you know
self-hosting all parts of parts of our
stock
um but you know these are multi
multi-vendor
um engagement so I was with somebody on
the gcp team earlier with a shared Telco
customer and
um the gcp friend asked the Telco friend
uh wait a minute I thought you guys were
using us for you know XYZ uh support use
case and the reality is that like in the
Enterprise there are so many use cases
and the the the the the models
um strengths and this is what's so nice
about vertex Ai and just the the
hopefully the depth of the models that
are going to be there
um what you're using them for um
uh is is is really
um knowing that use case is a big part
of uh it plays a big role in kind of
choosing the right the right model so
you know with that let's uh talk about
the the first one exam works is the
company that you know big Healthcare
um payers will Outsource you know a
complicated uh Health claim to so
somebody's got like a 200 Grand surgery
that they need to uh um make sure the
claim is you know uh being supported the
right way what we're able to do
is number one and you can see the color
coding uh on the use cases this really
helps us even understand and sort of
start having heuristics for all right um
you are doing a create use case so we've
got a really wide context window
depending on the length and the
complexity we should be able to do
everything in in the prompt
um a lot of times that's not the case
especially in claims management where
you end up actually fine-tuning by uh
area so disability separately from in
claims management separately from
accidents separately from Etc so in this
case what we were able to do on the
creation side is actually create you
know an automatic summary and the
summary is and this is where Knowledge
Graph comes in really handy what you're
really doing is taking uh perhaps
something not the patient will have
filled out uh you're going in and you're
looking at
um uh their policy you're comparing it
uh to anything that might have changed
given their condition since in this
summary
um uh feeds into a decision-making
process where a doctor formally doing
all of this manually
is analyzing the material and actually
coming up with with a decision so we are
creating the summary that speeds up the
decision then we are helping to come up
with the decision and then there is a QA
process that they had been doing
manually with uh with nurses that then
actually reviewed sort of the shorthand
of doctors and made sure that it was
written out in in ways that complied
with uh the the
uh the company so uh you know these are
all things that we are doing off of
Palmyra Med and actually when we met
this customer the POC was being done off
of our open source Palmyra the 20
billion model and so they had already
been experimenting this wasn't with
vertex AI but it was really in being
able to bring kind of the knowledge
graph and the post-processing together
and then the techniques around being
able to kind of distill the problem down
into uh different use cases uh that
really brought the whole solution
together now of course we gave them a UI
Etc we've got kind of this composable
application layer on top uh but you know
that really wasn't what sealed it for
them it was really being able to get to
solving the problem that they thought
generative AI could could solve
at CVS this one's a bit more
straightforward um they've you know for
a long time had this ambition to help us
really get more Wellness information as
we get prescriptions filled and so
they're able to take information that
they've got on somebody's condition
somebody's age and really marry it with
what it is that's being prescribed for a
much more fulsome
description of what to do with your
medication than we normally get with
kind of our our shorthand Pharmacy or
pharmacist information
and um uh in that previous example I
don't know how to go backwards oh here
we go
uh in in this example
uh the training data didn't really exist
because they had never actually done
something like this before and so this
was a um a
example of a use case where you actually
use the model to generate some of the
first training data and you give it to
somebody for annotation right and that
actually becomes what we used for uh for
for fine tunings this was this was
interesting and you know everything from
the the Bolding to
um
how you structure the bullets to
Punctuation is actually happening in in
the AI guard rails part in
post-processing because you need a lot
more data formatted the exact same way
for an llm to be you know following your
formatting or structure if you're trying
to do everything within the prompt
in financial services there is a lot of
really interesting use cases now we've
got a thank you a financial services
um uh model that is also coming to
vertex and uh we've got some of our
early Financial Services customers in
wealth management and banking um who who
have started using the model so you know
what's nice about
um really having a composable stock in
generative AI is you can upgrade the
models without needing to rebuild all of
the use cases and what we're seeing is
as folks get more sophisticated these
are some of the considerations which is
why I think a lot of what you guys are
are building at Google is so important
because we're still in that phase of
trying to you know build
and use the biggest models possible but
you know over time folks are realizing
you know more focused smaller is going
to be better but you don't want to lose
everything that you have built that
you've built on top and Vanguard are
great examples of that
um this is an example of a chat
application kind of a what we call
scaled q a
um that they have built within within
writer I'm going to skip across the
retail example and talk about what's
next for for us and Google
um it's been a really awesome kind of uh
Journey from the Google startup program
to where we are today with with Google
and so many of our joint customers from
L'Oreal to Verizon are very excited that
they're going to be able to use writer
from within from within Marketplace so I
can't speak more highly of the the
Google folks and their appreciation for
the startup journey in all of its phases
uh highly encourage everybody to scan
this code and get all of these credits
um You didn't hear it here but you may
actually get more credits than are on
this slide if you ask real nicely
but thank you so much Caitlyn it's uh
it's great working with you all
and uh we'll be out front in the lounge
if you have any questions but thank you
guys so much it was great talking to you
thank you